Titanic was released in December of 1997.
Many Hollywood insiders and naysayers predicted
doom for the film. After all, it had cost
a record $200 million to produce; the story
had been told on film more than once; everyone
already knew the ending; and the film really
had no “big stars” to draw in the crowds.
(Originally the lead role was to go to Mathew
McConaughey to provide the “star power”,
but director James Cameron and Kate Winslet
both pushed for DiCaprio to get the role.)
After making a good, but not incredible, $28
million in its opening weekend, momentum (and
great word of mouth) quickly set in. Titanic
soon set a “never to be broken” highest
grossing film record (that was in fact soon
to be broken by Avatar). It was the number
one film at the box office an unbelievable
15 weeks in a row. Titanic eventually grossed
a record $600 million in the United States
alone in its first run. It became the first
movie to gross over $1 billion worldwide and
after the recent 3D release is up to $2.185
billion, making it just the second film over
$2 billion with Avatar (though, when adjusting
for inflation and ticket prices of the day
films were released, Titanic is only considered
the 5th highest grossing film of all time).
It wasn’t just a hit in the Western world
though, something about Titanic tugged at
the heartstrings of Afghan boys in a way no
other American love story ever had. Previous
to this, most Hollywood movies that made it
big in Afghanistan were almost exclusively
action movies, with Rambo III probably holding
the title for most popular American movie
in Afghanistan, being “dedicated to the
brave Mujahideen ﬁghters of Afghanistan”.
Despite the Taliban’s strict ban on American
cinema, VHS copies of Titanic flooded Kabul’s
black markets.
Titanic-mania swept the country and had a
resurgence after the Taliban were removed.
Before the crackdown (and after the government
was overthrown), posters of the film could
be seen hanging on countless Afghan walls.
Even extra-large vegetables, from tomatoes
to cucumbers, started to be referred to as
“Titanic Vegetables”. There was also “Titanic
Mosquito Killer”, “Titanic Body Spray”,
“Titanic Toothpaste”, “Titanic Sandals”,
“Titanic Wedding Cakes”… you get the
idea.
One fabric seller in Kabul, Ali Ahmad, states,
“Still everyone plays Titanic. Because the
story is good. It’s a real story. That’s
why people still like it. And the love parts
— that’s what we like.”
But alarm bells didn’t start going off for
the country’s fundamentalist government
until teenage boys started emerging from downtown
barbershops sporting DiCaprio-style “Titanic
haircuts”. This incited the rage of the
Taliban and soon the police started cracking
down.
Numerous teens and at least 30 barbers were
arrested because of the DiCaprio cut, others
were simply beaten and forced to shave their
heads. Because of this, many Afghan boys sporting
the new cut took to wearing hats, caps, or
turbans to hide their manes when they were
in public. Older young men (yep, I just wrote
that) actually grew beards to try to blend
in better while sporting their “Titanic”
cuts.
Brave barber Aminullah Nazif, who never actually
saw the film, was not to be dissuaded though
and started giving the Titanic cut in secret,
with the first customer he had who requested
it showing him a Leo DiCaprio postcard and
asking to be given the “Titanic” cut.
Nazif became a popular “underground barber”
among Titanic-loving male teenage customers,
with many of his customers arranging to meet
at his shop late at night to get their Titanic
cuts.
As one 16 year old, Nawid Mirkhail, who got
the Titanic cut, but then was forced to have
it shaved off said, “I like the hairstyle
of the film star… He was a handsome boy.
And he looked very handsome with that haircut.”
While every movie star is probably at some
point flattered by imitations of himself (or
herself), DiCaprio may well be the only movie
star in history whose followers risked a physical
beating and potential arrest for imitating
his hair style.